now is steve malloy former trump epa
transition team member founder of
junkscience.com steve um
react to the angle because look they do
wrap this up in this very laudable goal
of reducing traffic fatalities which i
think everyone would like to see a
reduction in traffic fatalities but they
use that statistic
from 2021 comparing to 2020 when we had
major lockdowns and shutdowns across the
country how valid is that
well lori you did a great job in the
angle you tied it all together
beautifully um
you know they've hated the car for a
long time i wrote about this 13 years
ago in my book green hell they're trying
to figure out how to get us out of cars
they've tried climate it's not working
so well people don't really want to buy
evs
i guess now they're going to try traffic
fatalities it doesn't make any sense
you're right their use of statistics is
dishonest that's nothing new
um
you know people are going to be
surprised when they start going back
downtown to work they're going to find
that it's going to be a lot more
inconvenient for cars because while
we've been away during the pandemic
local governments have been making it
more difficult to drive your car park
your car speed limits have been reduced
parking areas have been reduced uh
gasoline prices are up you know the
government and the buy demonstration
especially is doing everything it can to
make it more difficult to drive why they
want to do that they don't like cars
they don't like what cars enable which
is as you mentioned living in in the
suburbs but also isn't this
partly a control thing
as it was with covid i mean they didn't
really care about the virus when the
border was open and you know millions of
people were crossing the border without
really being tested or any control so
that that whole thing was a joke from
the beginning but same with this correct
i mean you
you can't just jump in an electric
vehicle at least not right now and
travel
you know 500 miles
quickly or a thousand miles quickly yeah
the internal combustion
engine has given americans more freedom
or given the whole world more freedom
you can fill up your car in five minutes
and drive 400 miles in any direction you
can't do that with an ev
and now you know the government in the
infrastructure package there's a
provision in there the government they
want
the government to work on uh kill
switches so they can turn your car off
when they want uh you're right it's it's
all about control as is everything
environmental i've been working on
environmental issues for 30 years it's
never been about the environment it's
about controlling people what they do
well here's jen sake last week on the
importance of quickly ditching the
fossil fuel industry watch
it's a huge advantage to us to be a
leader
in the clean energy transition and over
the course of years and decades we've
become a clean energy superpower because
ultimately that's not just where the
jobs are it's where the strategic
advantage will lie in 10 20 30 years
so wait a second so
they think the white house thinks that
no one's going to be using oil in the
next 10 years really well china is going
to be using oil we know that
well yeah china's going to be using oil
and coal to make all the green tech crap
that you know we're forced to buy here
in america we're not a clean energy
superpower uh china is and you know we
should be the energy we should be the
oil and gas and coal superpower we have
all the energy in the world but
democrats don't want us to use it they
want us to become dependent on china
this whole green agenda
the more it passes the more mandates we
get for wind and solar at evs all it
does is make us more dependent on
communist china who is our geopolitical
enemy
all these all the materials most of the
vast majority of materials for green
tech comes from china and there's none
of these bills or regulations that have
been passed uh even even bother to
imagine that well we should you know
these materials really should come from
america if we're going to be requiring
them not from communist china because
we're just otherwise we're just it's
we're dependent on china oh well they're
they're absolutely fine with that you're
right now i have to get to this uh steve
this was also in the new york times
today
wanting americans to ditch beef
for a certain insect watch
unless we make major adjustments to the
food we eat and how we produce it we're
cooked
one of those dietary changes we need to
consider might even make you a little
squeamish and we're going to finish it
off with some whole grasshoppers yeah
we're talking about insects
specifically
eating them
steve i mean they're just like handing
the election to the republicans i think
we should just run that for the next
three years
and say uh do you want bacon bits or do
you want that on your salad well yeah
earlier this year they were i think both
the new york times and washington post
were advocating that people eat cicadas
and i think even on cnn some one of
their anchors it was just it was gross
they're crazy you're right steve
they would love nothing more than to
have a kill switch in the vehicles the
trucks
of the freedom convoy right they'd love
to just to be able to turn them off and
get them out of there or redirect them
to another location they would love that
technology right now then they would
have to deal with the pesky people uh
steve we love having you on thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else